ja wir von der queen irgendwann schreibt
ihr nur wendet sich thomas also wir sind
auch per du natur ja gut dann läuft
thomas von aquin der italienische
dominikaner mönch und philosoph thomas
von aquin hat im mittelalter ebenso wie
augustinus versucht mehrere
anforderungen in seiner theorie das böse
gerecht zu werden
ja das böse darf nicht ausgestanden denn
dies widerspricht seinem begriff von dem
begriff des bilden
ja da hat so wendet sich thomas zur
bestimmung des bösen den menschlichen
mal reingucken bringt diesen aber
zugleich in einer jungen hallo wir
lernen richtig viel wird ein buch lesen
wir alle ist mir manchmal